miguel no está seguro de cómo sumar 189
608 ayuda a miguel a elegir el problema
de suma que sea igual a 189 608
veamos las opciones todas las opciones
comienzan con una centena en el
enunciado en donde vemos una centena
pues aquí esto de aquí es una centena
y todas las opciones también tienen seis
centenas de dónde sale esto pues del 608
aquí está en las seis centenas lo que
representa este seis más seis centenas
y nuevamente todas las opciones tienen
ocho decenas todas lucen iguales hasta
este punto de donde sale en el 189 el 8
está en el lugar de las decenas por lo
que representa 8 decenas
qué más tenemos aquí comienza la
diferencia veamos uno por uno la primera
opción tiene nueve unidades de dónde
viene esto pues en el 189 este 9 está en
el lugar de las unidades lo que
representa más 9 unidades
y finalmente tenemos 8 unidades de donde
salió en el 608 tenemos el 8 en el lugar
de las unidades escribimos más 8
unidades
la primera opción luce bastante bien ya
que se toman en cuenta todos los dígitos
a excepción del 0 como lo indicaría mos
pues como está en el lugar de las
decenas escribiríamos más 0 decenas lo
que es 0 y no va a cambiar el valor de
esto por lo que nuestra primera opción
es igual al problema de suma original si
queremos ver la descomposición de las
otras opciones esto tiene ocho decenas
dos veces pero en el problema solo
tenemos una cantidad con ocho decenas el
otro ocho está en el lugar de las
unidades por lo que aquí debería decir
unidades en la tercera opción tenemos
las ocho unidades pero este nueve está
en las unidades no en las escenas así
que aquí debería decir unidades y es por
eso que no elegimos ninguna de estas dos
hagamos otro problema
cual problema de suma es el mismo que
525 379
vamos a descomponerlo tenemos 5 en el
lugar de las centenas son 500 y luego
tenemos un 3 en el lugar de las centenas
las 300
tenemos 12 en el lugar de las decenas 2
decenas o 20 más 20 y tenemos un 7 en el
lugar de las decenas más siete decenas o
más setenta finalmente tenemos cinco en
el lugar de las unidades más cinco y
nueve en el lugar de las unidades más
nueve cuál de estas opciones es igual a
lo que acabo de escribir
500 + 300 no está en la primera opción
así que podemos descartar la segunda
opción está 20 más 70 más 5 más 9 y es
justo lo que escribimos es la correcta
la tercera opción tiene un 90 en lugar
de un 9 y tiene un 7 en lugar del 70
puede ser 7 están en lugar de las
decenas y no en el de las unidades por
lo que eliminamos también esta opción